let us now look at an example consider a
piecewise constant PDF of the form shown
in this diagram suppose that we
condition on the event that X lies
between a plus B over two which is here
and B so we're conditioning on X lying
in this particular red interval what is
the conditional PDF the conditional PDF
is going to be zero outside the interval
on which we are conditioning so the
conditional PDF is zero in this range
and also it is zero in this range within
the range of values of X that are
allowed given the conditioning
information the conditional PDF must
retain the same shape as the
unconditional one and the unconditional
one is constant in that range so the
conditional PDF will also be a constant
because in this case the length of this
interval is half of the distance between
B minus a so the length of this interval
is B minus a over two in order for the
area under this curve to be equal to one
it means that the height of this curve
has to be equal to two over B minus a
the conditional expectation in this
example is just the ordinary expectation
but applied to the conditional model
since the conditional PDF is uniform the
conditional expectation will be the
midpoint of the range of this
conditional PDF and in this case the
midpoint is 1/2 the left end of the
interval which is a plus B over 2 plus
1/2 the right endpoint of the interval
which is B
and so this evaluates to one-fourth
times a plus 3/4 times B we can also
calculate the expected value of x
squared in the conditional model using
the expected value rule according to the
expected value rule it's going to be an
integral of the conditional PDF which is
2 over B minus a multiplied by x squared
and this integral runs over the range
where the conditional PDF is actually
nonzero so it's an integral that ranges
from a plus B over 2 up to B and this is
an integral which is not too hard to
evaluate and there is no point in
carrying out the evaluation to the end